this is olivia  a north american river otter  [Music]  olivia is only eight months old but is  quite the playful otter pup  river otters are semi-aquatic they live  both on land and in water and have  adapted for both environments  they have thick protective fur to help  them stay warm while swimming in cold  water and short legs and webbed feet to  help them swim quickly  river artists can stay underwater for as  long as eight minutes and use their long  whiskers to find prey in the often  cloudy waters in which they swim  in the late 1980s north american river  otters were extinct throughout many of  their natural habitats due to fur  trapping and poor water quality  through reintroduction programs and the  fur trade management their populations  have risen and stabilized  this is the north american river